[Música]
o psol o vírus é mais um vídeo e hoje
vou ensinar como fazer um barco que anda
sem precisarem de pilhas para isso vão
precisar desta placa aqui com o novo vai
estar na descrição deste vídeo e esse
projeto é bastante simples eu vou
começar por fazer o barco e para ser
resistente à água e ao fogo vou usar uma
embalagem dos uma dessas aqui te
atrapalhe o lado tamanho classificado e
outro tem esta camada aqui de papel de
alumínio como é que vocês quando fizerem
barco o papel da nintendo ficar dentro
para que o fogo não queima o barco ia
para classificada de ficar em contato
com a água
vêm as partes muito bem e isso vocês não
conseguiria fazer isso bem como não
podem usar algum objeto como estou
fazendo aqui causando um x ato
é muito importante que vocês que cortem
esse triângulos equipe para facilitar o
trabalho mais tarde vocês fizessem
explicando usando papel não se veriam de
tirar estes mini triângulos cuidado esta
parte aqui de reverter o barco porque
isso aqui é muito provável que o rasgo
na homicídio é tão fácil muito
devagarinho e depois de rasgar só usar
um pouco de cola e colarem de volta
nesta parte vocês usem luvas de proteção
e eu sei que aquela questão faça o que
eu digo não faça o que eu faço e nos
números porque minha pele muito grossa e
se usar luvas nunca ninguém controle do
que estou a fazer
[Música]
a fazer alice usei um pedaço de uma lata
e disney ela e depois me encontrei com
muito cuidado
agora se você estiver em celas de
plástico vem já com os motorzinhos que
tipo este aqui vocês podem usar que fica
melhor e isso tornou muito utilizado
para mim e android que os drones banco
primus então esse fator lula e também às
vezes nos 1004 tamanho
[Música]
você só tem que instalar um cabo ao
outro e já está pronto a utilizar não
sou daqui um pouco porque eu acho que
fica muito bonito nas filmagens do
fumacê e tauzin bem perto mas não
precisa fazer extração irregular um cabo
outro e já está pronto a utilizar
precisar também de uma vela e fuja só
colocar dentro da lata
se vocês quiserem podem colar à vela
para ficar lá banho fixa
depois é só usar em uma esquerda que
cumprido para acender a vela lá dentro
no final eu ainda disse iniesta
barbatana que mais de tubarão só pode
ser usar o barco só que eu percebi que
não é bem preciso uma vez que este barco
andando lentamente não usem óculos de
proteção por sócios da que seria
demasiado esta placa é lopota fechar
nenhuma coisa vocês gostariam que eu
fizesse vídeos explodir coisas ou seja
eu ponho uma seringa com a que esta
tenha aquilo podia fazer alguma coisa
deixe nos comentários que isso venha ter
existido espero contar com o vosso liga
da próxima champions
[Música]